I want to start with a question. How
many sales calls can you listen to and
take notes on in a single day? If you
assume each call is 30 minutes and you
work an 8 hour day with no lunch break,
that gives you 16 calls. If you have
absolutely zero work life balance and
only stop to sleep for 8 hours a day,
you might get to 32 calls. And if you do
that every single day, you'll get to 224
per week, doing nothing but listening to
sales calls over and over again. Last
year, our CEO wanted to analyze 10,000
sales calls in order to do a
wide-ranging analysis of our ideal
customer profile, and I had two weeks to
do it. Two years ago, this would have
been impossible, or would have at least
required a dedicated team working for
several weeks. today. It's something a
single AI engineer can accomplish in
about a fortnight. And I want to show
you exactly how I did it. At Pulley, our
ideal customer profile or ICP was
ventureback startups. It's a useful
north star from a product perspective,
but much less helpful when it comes to
marketing. We knew we needed to get more
specific. Think CTO of an earlystage
venture-backed crypto startup instead of
merely founder. And as every founder
knows, when you're trying to understand
your customers, there's really no
substitute for talking to them. In my
case, I had the next best thing.
Thousands of hours of our sales reps
talking to customers directly. The only
problem was it was too much
data. I want to paint you a picture of
what a manual analysis of this sales
call database would look like. It would
require downloading each transcript,
reading the conversation, deciding if
that conversation matches the target
persona you wanted to analyze, scanning
hundreds or thousands of lines of
conversation for key insights, trying to
remember everything while writing
reports uh and compiling notes as well
as citations for a future reference in a
research report. And then of course
doing this 10,000 times in a row. Even
if you wanted to do this manually, we're
talking about
625 days of continuous work, nearly 2
years, the human brain simply isn't
wired to process that much information.
It's like trying to read an entire
library and then write a single book
report about it. Before LLMs,
traditional approaches to doing this
kind of analysis generally fell into two
categories. a manual analysis that was
high quality but completely unscalable
and a keyword analysis that was fast and
cheap but would often miss context and
nuance. This is where modern large
language models come in. This
intersection of unstructured data and
pattern recognition, it's a sweet spot
for AI projects. But here's what I
learned. What looks simple in hindsight,
just use AI to analyze the sales calls,
actually required solving several
interconnected technical challenges. Our
first major decision was choosing the
right model. At the time, GPT40 and
Claude 3.5 Sonnet were the most
intelligent options that we had access
to, but they were also the most
expensive and the slowest. The
temptation to use smaller and cheaper
models was pretty strong, but our
experiments showed their limitations
rather quickly. They produced an
alarming number of false positives. They
would classify transcripts as being
related to crypto companies because a
sales rep mentioned blockchain features
on the platform. Or they might decide
that a prospect was actually the founder
of a company despite zero supporting
evidence in the transcript.
In our case, the worst outcome was a bad
analysis. If we couldn't trust the
model's data, the entire project would
be pointless. So, we made the choice to
shell out for the more expensive models
since they produced a hallucination rate
that was acceptable for our needs. In
the end, we ended up going with Claude
3.5 sonnet. I mentioned the
hallucination rate here because it also
wasn't as straightforward as feeding the
transcript in and asking for answers
out. We ended up developing a
multi-layered approach to reducing
hallucinations in this system. We
started with the raw transcript data
which we then enriched via retrieval
augmented generation both from third
party sources as well as other internal
sources that we had access to. We
employed some prompt engineering
techniques like chain of thought
prompting in order to get the model to
produce more reliable results. And
finally, we made sure to get structured
JSON outputs where possible in order to
generate
citations. This taken together created a
system that could reliably extract both
accurate company details and meaningful
insights. And more importantly, it had a
verifiable trail back to the original
transcripts where it was pulling
information from, meaning we could be
confident about the final results. The
main problem was doing all of this
analysis and making sure we had low
error rates drove up our costs pretty
significantly. We often hit the 4,000
token output limit for cloud 3.5 sonnet
which would require multiple requests
per transcript analysis. Luckily, we
were able to leverage two features that
were experimental at the time to
dramatically lower our costs. The first
was prompt caching. A lot of the
analysis that we did involved reusing
the same transcript repeatedly, both to
extract metadata and to extract
insights. By caching the transcript
content, we were able to reduce costs by
up to 90% and latency by up to
85%. The other feature we leveraged was
extended outputs. At the time, Claude
had an experimental feature flag that
could give access to double the original
output context. Using this flag let us
generate complete summaries in single
passes rather than having to break the
analysis into multiple turns and burning
multiple rounds of credits. As a result,
we turned a $5,000 analysis into a $500
one. And we got results in days instead
of weeks. But what ultimately surprised
me the most about this project wasn't
the tech technical capabilities that we
discovered or the challenges that we
overcame. It was the wide-ranging impact
of our
analysis. What started off as a project
for the executive team to produce
insights that would normally take tens
if not hundreds of hours ended up being
more useful across the organization. The
marketing team, for example, were able
to pull customers for branding and
positioning exercises that they needed.
and the sales team was able to automate
transcript downloads on the back of the
system, saving them dozens of hours
every week. On top of all this, teams
started asking questions that wouldn't
have been considered before because
doing manual analysis like this would
have been too daunting. In the end, we
transformed our mountains of
unstructured data from a liability into
an asset. So, what did we learn from all
this? I want to share three key
takeaways. First, models matter. Despite
the push for open- source and smaller,
cheaper models, Claude 3.5 and GBT40
could handle tasks that other models
simply couldn't. We chose Claude for its
prompt caching capabilities and its
accuracy, but in the end, the right tool
isn't always the most powerful one. It's
the one that best fits your specific
needs. Two, I want to point out that
good engineering still matters. Despite
AI's capabilities, we gain significant
wins from good old-fashioned software
engineering, leveraging JSON structured
output, good database schemas, and
proper architecture for the system as a
whole. AI engineering is knowing how to
build effective systems around large
language models. That means that the AI
can't just be bolted on or used as an
afterthought. It needs to be
thoughtfully integrated into existing
systems and architectures.
And we learned that we needed to
consider additional use cases for our
tech. We didn't just stop at a single
report or white paper. We built out an
entire UX around our AI analysis with
features like search filters and
exports. And by building a simple yet
flexible tool, what could have been a
one-off project actually became a
companywide resource. At the end of the
day, this project showed how AI can
transform seemingly impossible tasks
into routine operations. It's not about
replacing human analysis. It's about
augmenting it and removing human
bottlenecks. To me, that's the real
promise of tools like Claude, Chat, GBT,
Gemini, and all the rest. Not just doing
things faster, but unlocking entirely
new
possibilities. So, here's my challenge
to you. What customer data are you
sitting on right now? Sales calls,
support tickets, product reviews, user
feedback, and social media interactions.
These are all valuable sources of
insight that go untouched in most
companies, but are now very much
accessible via large language models.
The tools exist today. The techniques
work. The only question is when will you
stop ignoring your data and start
turning it into gold?
If you like this, you can read much more
about it and other projects like it at
my blog, Artificial Ignorance. Thanks
for watching.